[Music]
so
morning everybody it's seven o'clock
here in the uk you are very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news
pingdemonium panic is not going away
this morning with warnings of empty
shells
and cause for a change in those who are
exempt from self-isolation rules
to help keep critical workers working
the business secretary
quasi quatting on the show very shortly
plus the shadow home secretary nick
thomas simmons
also we'll speak to the liverpool actor
and comedian ted robbins to hear why
and what his take is i should say on why
liverpool is no longer
the taj mahal of the northwest
singing for safety we'll speak to the
songwriter who wants to help women
not fear getting home at night
it's thursday the 22nd of july pandemic
pressure warnings of empty shells
and fuel shortages prompt calls for the
government to make more critical workers
exempt
from self-isolation
i'm in yakuza siberia been up to the
arctic
and to the wildfires racing through the
siberian forests to witness with my own
eyes
the confluence of calamities affecting
good morning the extreme heat warnings
are still in force across parts of the
uk and
ireland very hot day to come yet again
today and a warning to take care
if you're trying to keep cool in this
heat
and we're live in tokyo the day before
the opening ceremony of the olympics and
they've fired the guy
who's put it all together and we've got
news of who will be carrying the flags
for team gb ruin lives calls for the
government and sports bodies to address
the dangers of brain injury in sports
my concern is about the future you know
will i have to go into a home will i be
able to remember things or remember
memories of my kids will i be able to
remember about actually playing this for
and happy birthday to george kensington
palace released a new picture of the
prince
who is eight today
now if you thought pandemic was going to
be a short-lived phrase then
it is not it's causing new fears today
over empty shop shelves and fuel
supplies because of the sheer number of
people
self-isolating that's led to calls from
the british retail consortium for the
government to change its guidance
on self-isolation to exempt more double
jab critical workers
as so many are getting pinged by the nhs
kovid app let's have a look at it in
more detail shall we the british retail
consortium has now urged the government
to change self-isolation guidance to
help
tackle the pandemic by exempting more
critical workers
from self-isolation rules meanwhile the
national police chief's council has said
response times are under strain
amid staff shortages with officers
having to self-isolate
and bp says lorry drivers are being
forced to self-isolate causing temporary
fuel supply issues
at some petrol stations it's led to
warnings from industry bosses including
those in retail
who've warned that food supply chains
are starting to fail
because of workers having to quarantine
we see
over the coming you know five days the
situation get worse and worse
and it's almost exponential the pinging
we're seeing in fact we've actually lost
uh two distribution sites uh due to the
pandemic and we're having to staff those
from uh other parts of the uk we just
need some clarity some steering
some clear guidance so that we can go
out and do what we do well
and that's all we're asking for as a
business
being pinged meanwhile politicians are
also being pinged uh the labour leader
kirstama is isolating for a fourth time
after one of his children
tested positive for covid19 and boris
johnson is in quarantine until monday
after getting too close
to the health secretary sergey javid who
has covert
well the business secretary quasi
kwateng is with us hello good morning
thanks for joining us on the program
just how worried are you about this
pigdemonium
and the impact that it's having on the
country obviously we're very concerned
about the situation
i spoke to representative members of the
brc that you mentioned the british
retail consortium
other people and we're monitoring the
situation
okay but how we've seen the shelves
we've seen the supermarket shelves
there's literally no food there
petrol pumps are running out we need to
start looking at who can be
exempt from having to self-issue and
that's what we are doing we're going to
announce
a list of exempt workers the list of
exemptions will be quite narrow
because obviously you have to draw the
line somewhere and what we want to do is
to keep people safe
and that's why we have the
self-isolation policy in the first place
who's going to be on it
um i can't tell you well uh because
you'll have to wait and see when we
announce the list
why are we still waiting um because we
have to work out we've been talking
about
it since well we've been talking about
it for a very long time certainly since
monday i've been asking your colleagues
we've seen what's happening on the
supermarket shelves literally people
cannot get food they cannot get fuel to
put in their
as i said we're monitoring the situation
i don't think i mean there are reports
do you need
we need quite a bit because we have to
see what the situation is across the
country and there are different reports
from different areas but as i said uh
we're going to come up with a list of
exempt
workers uh very soon okay so we have
seen who was on the list previously
haven't we when it came to um
workers who were key workers during the
first lockdown in march of last year
is that a good starting point well last
year was uh
the critical point there was in terms of
energy infrastructure things like
nuclear power stations and there was a
real critical focus on that and as i
remember last year
it did take time uh to come up with the
list um and this time
well you've got something already now
haven't you well it's a slightly
different situation because of course
this time we've got
people protected yeah there's a starting
point i think you're quite right but
we're going to have to review the list
and see
who the people are this time that we
think should be examined
when will you know um we should know
very soon i mean i can't give you
exactly the exact minute
um but i'm not looking for the minute i
mean a day would be good a day would be
good but
clearly it's something of real urgency
and we want to do it as quickly as we
can by the end of the week
i can't give you a a limit um but i
would like to see
you know people at home this morning are
watching no i understand i i completely
i literally can't get baby food for the
baby i completely understand it's a
difficult situation but we need to
uh review all the information that we
can okay and then we'll come up with a
list
very soon okay so why can't they here's
an idea why can't
key workers use the pilot scheme that
the prime minister was going to use and
the chancellor was going to use and
michael gove
did use in order to test to release so
we've got to work out who the key
workers are and that's what we'll do and
we'll come out with a list okay
i'm going to give you a list let's start
with lorry drivers
i'm not going to play a game with you
sorry how can you say it's a game have
you seen the shelves
i know it's a critical point but i've
said to you not a games
minister um kay i said to you three
times the
list is going to be uh coming out soon
and i'm not going to prejudge
what what's on the list and who the
workers who will be exempt
uh dropping self-isolation for double
jab from the 16th of august
is that definitely going to go ahead as
i always used to say
we always review the information a week
before and then we make the decision
just as we did with the 19th of july
with the 21st of june when we postponed
it was always a week before
and i think a week before the 16th of
august we will be able to make a
decision on as to whether the
restrictions will be lifted
friend rang me yesterday she was very
very excited about her weddings third
time it's been cancelled
um the groom's been pinged that's
terrible i mean a terrible situation but
you know we are in a very very difficult
uh
shouldn't go ahead with the wedding it's
completely uh an unusual
uh phase that we're in and i think so
far the rules are clear you've got to be
so you've got to self-isolate so that
they should
they shouldn't go i don't know what the
arrangements will be well if they've
been paying they should just shouldn't
go ahead with the wedding well i mean
it's yeah i mean i suppose that's that's
exactly the right thing yeah lisa andy
was on the show yesterday
um the shadow foreign secretary um she
said that she completely understood why
people were switching off
the app um or deleting it all together i
don't know if you saw the yougov poll
that was suggesting that basically
um i think a third of people were not
using the app and of those that are
20 were not using the test and trace
part of it
um do you have sympathy i i think it's a
real shame
that people are doing that because we're
not doing this simply for fun we're
doing
uh these rules we're putting in place
these rules to protect
uh everybody and i think that the whole
point about self-isolation is that we
we're protecting
uh wider society and i think people
should be following the rules
you don't you don't at any stage switch
it off
no what happens got it on that what are
my phone switched off now yeah
what about when you're in the chamber
yeah it could be anywhere
yeah so if you are in the chamber and
then people like oh i don't know
kiestarma
is there and then he has to self-isolate
potentially he could
have coveted from one of his children
you're looking at pingdemonium in the
chamber aren't you well you could do i
mean it's disruptive i mean there's no
there's no
but it's not sustainable is it well and
my point is that the restrictions
fingers crossed will be lifted on the
16th of august i'm confident they will
be but i can't guarantee that but
can we limp along until then um i think
we're going to have to follow the rules
until the 16th of august i know it's a
long time but it's not going to last
forever
and i think that once the restrictions
are lifted we can get back to normality
i don't know how people are going to
feel about that this morning but let's
see i'm sure
of course it is of course it is um but
you know i've got to be as clear as i
can about about where we are
yeah i just i just don't you know people
watching this morning will be thinking
i can't get the food i need for my
family i can't get the fuel i need
to go to work um nurses and frontline
workers potentially can't go to work to
save other people's
lives because they're being forced to
self-isolate and they haven't got
covered
and we have an option to test and
release them it's a difficult situation
i don't recognize the bare shelves that
you've described clearly in some places
have you not seen the pictures i have
seen pictures um in the papers
clearly that is happening i don't think
it's universal across the country
i also think that we have to protect our
people against
what's been a terrible pandemic yeah
okay let me talk about um
those are some of the pictures let me
talk to you about um the nhs three
percent for nurses
um they are threatening industrial
action they say that's nowhere near
enough for them and they are looking at
something like uh 12 and a half percent
is what the unions want
they've literally risked their lives for
us haven't they over the last
18 months or so um three percent
so when this came up a few months ago
the proposal was
uh a freeze uh we looked at we said
there'd be an independent uh
consultation an independent review
and the independent review it's
independent it's not the government
saying this the independent review has
recommended
three percent uh increase and the
government uh has decided that that's
uh that we would go with the independent
review and i think that's
entirely fair obviously we'd like it to
be more but
you have to remember that we spent 350
billion pounds
to deal with a pandemic to pay for
furlough to pay for
other support loans that have been given
to companies
and i think three percent which was
after all what the independent review
came up with
uh is is a fair number twelve and a half
percent or going on strike or
certainly threatening industries i mean
you'll appreciate that's a huge increase
in a year which would be uh very
impossible to afford
and i think that um everyone understands
that the nhs has been
heroic through this period the
independent review
uh said three percent uh and we've
agreed with that
um is that a way to reward people though
who have
literally risked their lives many having
lost their lives on
the front line when potentially that is
going to be a below
inflation rise i don't think it is
necessarily going to be
below inflation rise we don't know what
the inflation figure will be
but as uh you will remember when this
came up a few months ago
there was uh outcry about the fact that
it was going to be it was going to be
held flat
or it was a one percent rise actually uh
we went to an independent uh panel
review they came up with the number
three percent which is more than
was suggested at the beginning and we've
decided that that's that that
makes a lot of sense and that we should
stick to that yeah matt hancock said
that he didn't have any more money so
was it coming from
matt hancock um said yes at the time he
said there was
no money the independent panel has said
three percent and we've decided that we
can we can afford that
how are you gonna pay for it um we're
going to pay for it through
um general taxation as we pay for for
everything but no increases in taxation
not that i i understand because i was
chatting to one of your colleagues
earlier on in the week i can't remember
who it was now
he was sat here and was telling me that
um
absolutely under no circumstances would
there be an increase
in national insurance because of course
that's what it says on the front page of
your manifesto that's what it says in
the manifesto i don't see how we could
increase national insurance but
you know things have have been very
flexible over the last 18 months we've
lived through an unprecedented time
we've seen we've been spending huge
amounts of money that we never thought
was possible
um and it's up to the chancellor and and
his and the treasury and the wider
government to decide
a budget that the budget isn't uh isn't
due for a few months now i wonder how
you're going to pay for social care
that's again another question that we're
debating within government
my understanding is that we will have a
policy uh
by the autumn um but we'll have to wait
and see
but you won't put up taxation for that
either i don't think we'll put up
national insurance um
that specific uh what night you put up i
don't know i mean it's
part of a general debate that we have
within the government
about how we can balance all these
priorities and you know these are
difficult questions as you know
and many viewers will appreciate that
you know in their own uh household
spending you've got to make
uh difficult decisions when you're
thinking about a government and you're
thinking about billions
of pounds and millions of people um
they're looking so you could have tried
a pandemic exactly totally get it
totally get it but
you know you might have to break your
manifesto promise i hope we don't but
um let's see where we are well i'm not
ruling anything in or out i never do in
these interviews i've just got to be
very clear
about the difficult choices that we have
to make and also the other thing that
we've got to remember is that we don't
know
in three months time where we'll be with
the pandemi we don't know
um what the state of the finances will
be we don't know what the state of the
economy
will be so it doesn't make any sense uh
to rule that many things
in or out at this stage would you go
abroad at the moment i personally
wouldn't
um why not because i like staying at
home
um and also i think that uh it's less
complicated actually
uh if you just stay at home and enjoy
the because you can get caught out when
you're overseas and then suddenly things
change and
the thing is about going overseas is
that there are rules over there as well
it's not just a question so so it does
it can complicate things
um you know if people go to france
they'll be subject to rules in france so
the french were saying they might uh
expect british people going to france to
quarantine
and those rules change so for this year
this summer
i've made the decision uh to stay stay
at home
yeah i mean on a personal level my
flights for my holiday have been
changed yet again it's the fourth time
for the holiday over the last 18 months
that they've been changed
and i'm mentioning that because i'm sure
a lot of my viewers are in a similar
position
so you're saying probably on balance
it's best
just to limp through to the end of the
year and then see where we are next year
that's my personal choice
um i'm not here to tell people how to
live their lives in respect
you're here to offer guidance and advice
um my own personal choice
uh would be to stay at home but i think
if people want to
go abroad then then you know they should
do that let's talk about brexit should
we
um minus it's always very complicated
brexit let's see
what we can do with it the british
government wants to renegotiate the deal
with the eu is my understanding your
party won an election on the strength
of the deal going ahead the government
signed the deal
shouldn't we just honor it now so with
the um
northern ireland protocol uh obviously
nobody had any idea
uh the actual effects of it until it
we left bret we left uh the eu so we had
to look at how it operated
um after we left the eu we've looked at
it there have been difficulties with it
and we think that
it's not satisfactory as it is so we
want to be in a situation where we can
actually renegotiate it
the normal island protocol isn't written
in in stone it's not something that was
going to last
forever and more everybody realized at
the time just a few months and also
nobody knew no one knew am i not right
in saying that at least
three previous prime ministers warned
that this would happen nobody could
guarantee i should
i should have been more careful with my
words nobody could guarantee what would
happen until
it actually happened and we left the the
eu
i think that what we've seen is that the
eu have been
a bit inflexible uh on on the protocol
and we want to be able to see if we can
make it work more smoothly a deal's a
deal there isn't it
a deal is a deal um but it wasn't
something that was going to last for
in forever nobody thought that the
northern ireland protocol was going to
define
the the role of northern ireland within
uh within the uk forever ever more it
was something that
was was flexible and we wanted to make
it work more smoothly
well as i said um the eu have got a very
different
view on that but let's see where we are
i mean i remember um being on programs
like this saying that you would never do
a deal
um and of course we did a deal because
they thought we were going to honor it
and we're not going so
so you'll remember uh that two years ago
people said we were never going to get a
deal from the eu but we did
so when people say they're not going to
look at the protocol again i say well
let's let's just see
okay final thought any likelihood that
the uk could trigger
the artist called 16 break which would
mean that basically
there'd be all sorts of mayhem in
northern ireland so um
the article 16 break as you as you point
out is in the protocol
it's something that we could do to
suspend it we've chosen not to do that
that's not our opening position
and we want to be able to negotiate and
have a conversation with the eu about
how best to go forward
okay good to talk to you i have to let
you go thank you very much for joining
us really appreciate it thank you
still to come on the programme for you
we've got some of the front pages this
morning
and their take on the pindemic this is
what it's looking like
starting with the murrah which says
shops are running on empty as thousands
of workers are hit
by the ping democ the mail also sums up
worries over supermarket food supplies
calling it
one of the shocking tolls of the
pandemic
pings are running out empty shells are
also making the front
of the sun this morning
still to come on the program the shadow
home secretary nick thomas simmons joins
us at
8.05 later in the programme speaking to
the man who's campaigning for better
safety gear for paddleboard users to
create
a legacy for his friend who lost his
life while out on the water
that's at around 20 past eight we speak
to the former team gb
bob slayer who was forced to retire
after a crash left her with a head
injury
that's at 8 30.
a two-pronged environmental disaster is
unfolding in the russian arctic which
could release billions of tonnes of
carbon into the atmosphere
with consequences for us all there's a
big thaw off the permafrost
in siberia and at the same time forest
fires are burning through millions of
acres
of land i'm oscar correspondent diana
magna joining us now from yakutsk
which is in siberia hello to you donna
good morning tell us more about this
hi kay well first of all i flew up deep
into the arctic circle to assess what
was going on
with the permafrost to a permafrost
research station up there
and really all you have to do is poke a
stick into the huge number
of newly formed ponds caused in
permafrost depressions where the ground
has caved in and you see methane
bubbling up and that is an indication of
the greenhouse gases methane and co2
that are contained in the permafrost
that as our planet warms
as the climate gets warmer that
permafrost
gets warmer too starts to thaw and it
releases
these greenhouse gases permafrost is
basically
the permanently frozen soil which sits
about
30 centimeters or lower beneath the
topsoil and it can go for
tens hundreds of meters it covers
two-thirds of the landmass
of russia so where i am now is uh
permafrost
and a quarter of the northern hemisphere
so you can imagine
how many gigatons one thousand four
hundred gigatons and a gigaton is
literally an incomprehensibly large
number
of carbon is what is contained in the
soil far more
than is contained in the earth's
atmosphere it is gradually thawing
and as it does it is accelerating
climate change further
then i came uh back further south to
yakuza here in siberia
the airport was closed for a couple of
days which delayed us coming back
because
of the smoke from wildfires and
yesterday we went out with some
firefighters to see for ourselves what
was going on
there are wildfires raging across
several russian regions but here in
yakutia and yukudsky is the capital of
yakutia
it is worst 1.5 million hectares
affected because it's been an
exceptionally hot summer it's about 28
degrees here today
it's been 39 degrees here bear in mind
it gets to minus 55 in winter and you
can see the kind of extremes
that people in siberia have to deal with
and the problem with these wildfires is
that as they burn
they burn forests which are carbon sinks
in and of themselves
they release carbon that's contained in
trees and vegetation
and they saw the permafrost so it's
literally
a triple whammy effect of climate
calamities that i've witnessed
okay thanks so much indeed thanks a lot
donna and you can watch diane's report
throughout the day here
on sky news meantime that remember those
uh wildfires that we're talking about in
northern california
they spread to nevada forcing more
people to evacuate
from their homes the fire has been
burning since the
fourth of july and was one of nearly two
dozen blazes sparked by lightning
strikes
smoke from the fires in california and
oregon has been spotted
as far away as the east coast and indeed
in spain
not in spain in space probably in spain
as well let me tell you about this at
least 33 people have died eight are
still missing after flooding in china's
henan province
that according to officials there heavy
rain turned into severe flooding on
tuesday
causing the streets to turn to rivers
and trapping people as water filled the
subway as you saw yesterday more rain
forecast for the next few days and you
can keep up with all the stories
affected
by the global climate on the daily
climate show right here on sky news
6 30 and 9 30 every single day
now there's a call for urgent action to
address the risks of brain injury and
sport we've spoken to some former sports
stars
who know only too well the hidden damage
it can do
shiman freeman powell reports
lenny woodard has dedicated his entire
life to rugby
he expected the sport to take a toll on
his body
but was shocked when he was diagnosed
with dementia
at 45. i still think i'm 21 in the head
but i don't know
i'm 45 and um and
and i shouldn't be feeling like this now
and what's even more tragic has come
from the game that i absolutely adored
and loved
um and uh yeah this concern is
concerning it
it's my concern is about the future you
know
will i have to go into a home will i be
able to remember things or i remember
memories of my kids will i be able to
remember better actually playing sport
the diagnosis has turned his life upside
down
although in the early stages he's
already lost out on work as a result of
his illness
and says it's starting to impact his
life
simple things like you would go to a
shop and forgot where you've got the
shop for or you walk into a kitchen to
get something but then you get in there
and have a mind blank
i started getting more frustrated um and
then you said
i i've been you know never raised my
voice um never become angry but start to
get
angry now and again road rage and things
like that and lenny is not alone
richard represents 175 former
professional rugby players with brain
injuries
he says this is not what the players
signed up for
everyone knows from an early age that
it's a dangerous rough game however what
all our guys
are angry about is that they didn't know
the risks of brain injuries
no guy or woman signs up to play rugby
to get early onset dementia
at the age of 35. the report found in
sports buddies to mark its own homework
former england rugby player kieran
bracken agrees
and says over the years the game has
become much more dangerous
the system is failing it's absolutely
failing players are playing
having been knocked out and hopefully in
time to come that won't be allowed
players will have a longer rest
and we can make sure that these players
have a longer career and rugby is
sustainable
mps are calling on the government to
draw up a firm definition
on what concussion is and impose new
rules that all sports
must follow shimon freeman powell sky
news
we'll have more on that with a former
bobsley champion later on the programme
now harvey weinstein has pleaded not
guilty to 11 charges of sexual assault
in los angeles
the former hollywood producer appeared
in court after losing his bid to block
extradition from new york
where he's serving a 23-year sentence
for rape
dubai has made its own artificial rein
to tackle its summer heat wave
the so-called cloud seeding project
involves using drones
to unleash electrical charges into
clouds which causes
rain it's part of an effort to create
more rainfall in a country that
typically only sees three to four inches
of rain a year
forty thousand people will head to
suffolk this weekend for
latitude which will be at full capacity
as a government test event
the four day music and arts festival
will become the first major event to be
held
following the lifting of most covid
restrictions in england
music headliners include wolf alice the
chemical brothers
and bombay bicycle club
and we'll have live coverage from
latitude here on sky news tomorrow
nasa's perseverance rover has begun
preparing to search for signs of ancient
life on mars launched in july of last
year it will use sophisticated sensors
to search its surrounding
area with the hope of one day providing
evidence
of life on mars
now kensington palace has released a new
photo of prince george marking his
eighth birthday the picture
of the heir to the throne the heir to
the air to the throne
taken by the duchess of cambridge shows
the prince smiling while perched on a
land rover
there you go and was taken earlier this
month in norfolk it's thought that he
was sitting on a land rover
in tribute to his great grandfather
prince philip of course who loved his
landis um sadly died
earlier this year so let's find out more
about the olympics there's now just
one day to go until the opening ceremony
in tokyo and we know who's going to fly
the flag for britain
do you want to know i bet you do let's
find out tom is in tokyo for us hey tom
good morning good afternoon where you
are
good afternoon kay yeah the flag bearers
have been announced by team gb
and we can tell you that they are two of
our very successful olympians hannah
mills
the sailor and also mohamed sabihi the
rower
so let me just tell you a little bit
about hannah first from south wales are
we so proud down at cardiff sailing club
where she started out and mo well he's
an enormous guy six
foot eight and his dad has got a barber
shop in london he used to sweep the
floors in that barber shop
and here he is carrying the flag for his
country
in the tokyo olympics um somebody who's
not going to be taking part in the
opening ceremony though is the guy that
sort of put it all together
yeah they're always multi-million pounds
spectacular aren't they but the creative
director of this one
has been fired overnight and
that is because they have unearthed some
comments that he made back
a couple of decades ago jokes about the
holocaust
and he has been fired simple as that he
won't
be taking any part they're reviewing all
the content of the show but
once that came to light that video then
it was a pretty
swift decision by the organizers and
he's gone so we'll play no parts in it
there will only be 950 people
inside the olympic stadium to see that
uh spectacular show it will be a made
for tv event
and uh the creative director he's gone
goodness me um so andy murray though he
is going to take part isn't he
he certainly is he loves the olympics
and we've been having a chat with him
this morning
he's been talking about how he's back to
try and win another gold medal at these
games and just
what it means to come and compete for
great britain for me
like it's just special to be part of an
olympic team and be part of the british
team it's like
you know we spend uh most of our careers
just kind of on our own at terms with
our own little teams and this is
something that's
bigger than that and like yeah i love
putting on the british kit and just
being around everyone so yeah hopefully
it goes well
obviously looking forward to hearing
more from him uh tom but there is
something a bit special about team gb
this year just sharing this with our
viewers
uh as well because we've actually got
eight sets of siblings or twins haven't
we in tokyo
yeah we've been chatting to some of them
uh jennifer
and jessica gadarova from aylesbury
gymnastics academy
they're going to be in the gymnastics
and hugely excited to be here we've also
been chatting some of the other
brothers and sisters or twins that have
been included in the squad
luke and pat mccormack wow they're
characters two
very likely lads from tyne and weir
berkley boxing club
up in the north east of england and they
are very very well tipped to do
very well here extremely proud and of
course all the athletes have to live
under these really tight covered
restrictions
not allowed out very much and they were
telling me that actually that suits them
because
in an ordinary games they'd be out and
about in tokyo and
getting up to all sorts so i think the
team around them in the boxing club are
quite pleased to be able to keep an eye
on them this time
okay and actually i was reading aleister
and johnny brown we we knew so much
about them from the last olympics only
one of them's qualified this time i'm
alright i'm saying
yeah that's right johnny is going alone
he won bronze in london in the triathlon
silver in rio he's going for gold that
of course has been
his brother's medal but alistair sadly
hasn't qualified he is out here here in
japan
doing some work uh looking to get
elected in some athletics kind of
political
movement and kind of trying to forge a
new
career but what a talent that family has
uh in both of those brothers but only
johnny here today he's converted his
conservatory
up in yorkshire into a heat chamber to
try and get used to the temperatures
in tokyo he's now out here ready to
compete in the triathlon but also
i have to say we're told that the
women's triathletes
from team gb are looking very strong as
well so
the triathlon is certainly one of the
events where we're looking to get some
medals and johnny brownlee
looking for that gold medal the one so
far that's looted him
fantastic and there's um tell me about
an athlete that's got their own twitter
hashtag is that right
yeah most people i think would have
heard of simone biles this
uber gymnast from the united states who
seemingly can do anything she takes on
the kind of moves in gymnastics that
other people
just aren't quite brave enough to do and
she's got this new hashtag with a goat
dressed up in a gymnastics outfit
that is her trademark i suppose on
social media now
not everyone gets one of them and it's
probably an indication of just how
special she is
yeah i think that you should have one as
well tomorrow we'll work on that thanks
very much for now tom thanks a lot we'll
see you in the next hour tom
in tokyo for the next uh three
weeks tune in every morning 7 30 and
9 30 for tom in tokyo
always important to treat yourself to a
little pampering and
elephants frankly are just no different
these photos from a zoom in belgium show
an african elephant getting
a pedicure keepers uh use a power
grinder to trim the toenails of the big
animals
part of a regular treatment the zoo has
23 elephants the largest herd
in europe i'm not sure that they paint
their nails but as you can see they're
very happy
with their pedicure when it's at the
front is it a manicure i'm not sure
uh what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned continuing to be
hot kirsty
oh yes indeed it is very hot key at the
moment and
of course that brings with it quite a
lot of risks but changes are
looming for the weekend
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello there the hot and settled sunny
spell continuing then today
we still have our extreme heat warnings
in force now that's for parts of
south wales midlands southwest england
and northern ireland in particular
and now the temperatures are just so
high both by day and by night
that really is making it quite difficult
to sleep and also as people try and keep
cool there have been some water safety
incidents so it really is
something we're trying to remind people
just to take extra care heat is
slightly more dangerous we do enjoy the
thought of summer but when it comes
we really can't quite cope very muggy
night again so very warm start today
that low cloud across the north and the
east burning back to the coast although
the northern isles may stay rather gray
lots of strong sunshine then very high
uv levels of course don't forget the
sunscreen
and the temperatures rising high 20s if
not the low 30s
parts of the midlands wales northwest
england like to be very hot today
could just see a few showers but those
will fade away and again another
sultry night to come
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and i make absolutely no apology for
banging on about
the open water issues six people have
now
died since the weekend because they have
jumped into water to try and cool off
and they've not known what was beneath
the surface we spoke to the rnli about
that yesterday please please please be
very
careful in this hot weather it's not
just the sun that you need to be
worried about you also need to be
worried about what is beneath the water
now the business secretary has told us
he's very concerned about a number of
people being pinged
by the nhs kervin 19 app he was speaking
as fears increased
over empty shop shelves and fuel
supplies because of the sheer number of
people self-isolating
quasi-quatern told me the government is
looking to increase the number of key
workers
exempt from being pinged because of
concerns
about those numbers being affected
we're very concerned about the situation
i spoke to
representative members of the brc that
you mentioned the british retail
consortium
other people um and we're monitoring the
situation
okay but however we've seen the shelves
we've seen the supermarket shelves
there's literally no food there
petrol pumps are running out we need to
start looking at who can be
exempt from having to self-issue and
that's what we are doing we're going to
announce
a list of exempt workers the list of
exemptions will be quite narrow
because obviously you have to draw the
line somewhere and what we want to do is
to keep people safe
i'm going to give you a list let's start
with lorry drivers
i'm not going to play a game with you
how can you say it's a game have you
seen the shelves
but i've said to you i'm against that
minister um
okay i said to you three times the wig
of the list is going to be
uh coming out soon and i'm not going to
prejudge
what what's on the list and who the
workers will be exemplar
when's the list coming out tomorrow i
think it's likely to be later today okay
this comes after the government said
just two days ago that they wouldn't be
a list it would be on a case-by-case
basis
and yes of course you can't tell by
social media pictures how widespread the
shortages in supermarkets are but
certainly all the major supermarket
names
have said that they're having problems
there's problems with getting petrol to
petrol pumps and this is all because
there is food there but it can't get to
the supermarkets because
lorry drivers are self-isolating retail
workers are self-isolating
and you know it's over the next few
weeks in danger of paralyzing parts of
that system um quasi quatting they're
very much saying we're going to have to
continue this until the 16th of august
if not longer
it's not a guarantee that it ends at
that stage
but how widely drawn will that list of
workers be
they're talking about it being very
narrow just people who run crucial bits
about
the electricity network and so on i
think there's going to be a real clamor
from tory mps to say we need a lot of
people in the retail sector
if we're not going to see these pictures
on our front pages every week well if
it's like that now what's going to be
like in three weeks
well we've already got over a million
adult self-isolating a million school
children
i think how far could could this go over
the next three weeks is the crucial
question being
discussed in government at the moment
we've got tomorrow's take on that
haven't we at nine o'clock
oh looking forward to it yeah thanks
very much tamara thanks a lot let's get
more now on this from dr ravi gupta he's
professor
of clinical microbiology at cambridge
university
and he is joining us live hello to
professor thanks so much indeed
for joining us what are your thoughts on
the number of people that
are being pinged and self-isolating is
it completely necessary
this is an interesting question so of
course the the the aim of
uh of of the the nhs tracing app is of
course to
to limit transmissions uh of coronavirus
we are now in a highly vaccinated
scenario
unfortunately the the unvaccinated
individuals are those who are young
uh below the ages of of 18 and of course
the
a lot of the transmission is happening
in this group and we also are seeing of
course
the the fact that even vaccinated people
are experiencing infections
because the delta variant is um uh is is
capable of of causing infection and
transmitting amongst vaccinated
individuals
although the good news is that of course
the rate hospitalization
and severe illness is greatly reduced
with the with the vaccine
so it's a difficult position at the
moment uh on the one hand we have
uh relaxed um uh all all restrictions
uh as it were uh legally and uh on the
other hand we are um
investing large amounts in uh test and
trace and
and also so um and of course by the app
we're isolating lots of people so
we need to really come up with a
coherent strategy we're either going to
limit infections at national level
in which case there should be a set of
uh um
rules or um measures in place
uh rather than a sort of mixed bag of of
measures which are creating confusion
and havoc as we can see
what do you say to people who say that's
it i'm going to delete this app
i think everyone has a personal choice
we've we've been um
uh advised uh that we have the choice to
to wear masks or not in public places
and um potenti potentially that is
something that people should be able to
do
in the current environment of of
government policy
i think it is a little bit difficult to
justify people
uh doing the self of the the isolation
uh when in fact we have held
huge sporting events with large amounts
of transmission uh
that have probably gone undetected so uh
it's a sort of half-hearted measure that
is affecting the lives of many people
uh many of whom will be depending on
their income on a daily basis
uh and for whom a week of isolation is
disastrous so
so um this is not a sort of call that i
could make but
all i would say is that if this was part
of a coherent strategy
where there was national buy-in with the
right messaging i don't think that this
would be such a problem
and we could have mitigation measures in
place so you don't think it's a coherent
strategy at the moment
no i don't think so because clearly we
we
are we have young people unvaccinated we
have measures in place now or
lack of measures to protect uh tran uh
people from
from being infected uh nationally and
uh no no measures in schools for example
when we go back in september
therefore one has to wonder what the
strategy is and if there is one
then it should be consistent across
different measures including vaccination
uh coverage into younger age groups
potentially understanding what long
covid is in
in individuals more thoroughly before we
allow
uh unfettered transmission to occur do
you think that we will find ourselves
being put under further restrictions
later on this year
it is going to be difficult to move back
and i think that um
again the sort of messaging uh rather
than saying this was a one-way streets
to freedom
could have been more nuanced and subtle
because people understand
what's going on globally people
understand there is a global emergency
and i think that there is sympathy and
and support
for uh continuing to keep our country
safe uh
and and so if we need to go back into
further restrictions
uh that is a possibility i believe
but the expectation setting again has
not really
been consistent with this and a safer
message from government
could have been we are going to open
things up
but things may not keep going the way we
want to because this is an unpredictable
virus
and we don't really understand the
long-term uh efficacy of vaccines for
example and how
uh declining and protection may
complicate matters over the next six to
twelve months
uh we uh opened up a normal well
freedom day whatever you want to call it
on the 19th how long do you think before
we see
the impact on cases as a result of
opening up
it's going to be at least four weeks i
would have thought
um and probably longer because
the the whole dynamic of covet 19
disease
is modulated or affected by some partial
immunity in individuals
through to vaccination or due to
previous infection and so
there may be quite a delay in seeing the
full effects of
uh of the opening up and i would um sort
of urge anyone
uh studying this uh or analyzing it to
just take that into account
and not jump to conclusions after four
weeks to say
here is what the the opening up did
in terms of health okay thanks very much
indeed let's bring in
dr tom dolphin should we he's a bma
consultants committee and a member of
the bma
council he's a consultant and he's
working in london
i know we are going to talk about pay
but i just wanted to pick up on that
before
we do do that doctor uh what do you
think how long do you think it might be
before
we see the number of cases rising as a
result
of freedom day good morning kay
i don't think it's going to be very long
the numbers were already on their way up
before
freedom day uh became a thing and
certainly the nhs
is already under pressure from
non-coveted work we've got record
attendances
quite a lot of a e departments we've got
elected surgery being cancelled in a lot
of places so what we really don't need
at the moment
is a lot of people turning up at
hospital with covid as well fortunately
as you just heard the numbers of people
being hospitalized with kovids
haven't risen quite so sharply but if
the numbers in the community keep going
up
inevitably the numbers coming into
hospital will come up as well and that's
going to affect
elective care planned care as well and
how do you feel about the nhs app and
people deleting it
it's very unfortunate i think if you
blame the app for it it overlooks the
point which is the app is reflecting the
huge rate of transmission in the
community the reason
there's a ping demo is because there's a
pandemic you know people are being
infected and testing positive in huge
numbers and blaming the app for that
is like blaming a fire alarm for going
off when there's a fire
um but not as many people are dying
of course as as we will know so that
chain thankfully has
been broken um and all the people that
are many of the people that are
isolating don't necessarily have covered
but nevertheless they can't
work for that week and we've seen the
supermarket shelves empty as a result
sure and it's certainly having an impact
on the economy i completely see that and
the the problem is that we've still got
some proportion of people who've been
vaccinated are still getting ill
if you've got millions of people all get
catching the disease
and only a tiny proportion of our ending
up in hospital that's still a large
number a small proportion
of a large number is still a big number
and hospitals as i say don't have a lot
of spare capacity at the moment we're
really stretched with everything else
quite aside from covid certainly there
needs to be some consideration of
whether people have been vaccinated
maybe could have
a different regime maybe as has
suggested they're you know being tested
to release
uh or something like that but at the
moment the numbers being pinged reflect
the numbers being infected because
we've released all the restrictions okay
um doctor you came on to talk about
the um three percent pay rise offer for
nhs
workers i mean it it's what has been
suggested recommended by
an independent pay body to the
government so there can't really be any
real argument with that can they
the pay review body that's made that
recommendation
has part of its purpose is to make sure
that
doctors want to stay in the nhs to make
sure that there's recruitment going on
and honestly over the last 10 years our
pay has fallen in value by about a third
because we've had year after year after
year of getting below inflation pay
rises
this doesn't really go very far towards
addressing that i mean inflation this
year is
projected to be more than three percent
andy holden at the bank of england is
talking about four percent
um so this is probably going to turn out
to be yet another below inflation pay
rise
at a time when doctors are leaving the
nhs they're exhausted by the last
year and a half and we really really
need people to stay this isn't going to
do that
okay um do you think that we sh that
your
your organization yours and nurses uh
other
uh health care workers um would
potentially consider
industrial action we're not at that
stage yet
what we're going to be doing uh we're
going to be sending out a survey to our
members
today and over the next week or so to
check and make sure that they are as
angry and disappointed about this
pay offer as as we are at the bma and
if so what they're prepared to do about
it and industrial action will be on that
list of things they might want to
consider
and we'll see what people are prepared
to do to defend their pay okay um
thank you on behalf of all of my viewers
for the amazing work that you do
thank you very much let's hope the
government recognises it too okay thank
you
in 2004 the city of liverpool was
awarded world heritage status
joining landmarks such as the great wall
of china and the taj mahal however it's
now been stripped of this status because
of new development work
on the waterfront which has been judged
to be detrimental
to the site's authenticity and integrity
joined now by liverpool-born actor and
comedian ted robbins hey ted it's good
to see you again thanks for joining us
on the programme
so basically it is uh it's basically
it's everton's fault
that liverpool is no longer the taj
mahal of the northwest
what you got to say about that well i
blame
chamier rovers or just over the water
um okay i i remember i was born in
liverpool went to school in liverpool
i remember in the 70s uh and before then
the docks were an absolute decaying
mouldering sight
lads used to take their air guns down
there and
take pot shots at rats you know it was
it was
well horrible and um
since then i've seen it develop i had a
flat in liverpool
i studied at college there on hope
street
uh the old notre dame college went to uh
first professional job
at the everyman so liverpool i've seen
it
grow and become this wonderful sort of
living embodiment of all that's good
you know the rant is over i'll throw a
quick joke in
because everyone says all scousers are
comedians only in liverpool
i i heard someone say on a bus hey lads
is this
is this bus going to stop at the peer ed
he said there'll be a really big splash
if he doesn't live and that's the kind
of there we are
oh i'm here all week but no my point is
that
it looks great everton whether you're
blue or red it doesn't matter
they're building a new stadium and you
know
it's about people it's not about
buildings
that will give thousands and thousands
of people employment cafes
revitalizing the place liverpool is has
never been better and some unelected
quango
in china apparently had a a blind ballot
quango i always thought that was an
orange drink but um
they've now decided wait for laugh
doesn't get it moves on
but uh
no no no like many of my audiences do if
i had an audience
i'm sorry i'm just ranting because it's
ridiculous
and the people of liverpool don't need
to be told as special heritage
you know people come from all over the
world just for example the beatles
there's the liver birds you know the
iconic symbols
do you know that just the beatles travel
industry um
brings in just shorts of 100 million
pounds
every year so in a decade that's nearly
a billion pounds
people coming from japan if you're from
america
if you go down matthew street uh where
the famous cabin club
was and is still and the grapes pub
where everyone used to hang around
there's even um a model of the
philosopher
carl jung who said famously that
liverpool
is the pool of life and um it
it is it's always had this it's got a
it's got the oldest
china town in europe you know
distinguished
it's always been a place where people of
all backgrounds have mixed together
and sure you know they remember you know
to get controversial the slave trade
is remembered respectfully the great
arch
the hundreds of years old
oh i think we might have lost him oh
he's back he's back
we lost you for a second but you're back
now i thought you're going to tell me
that if you want a cathedral you've got
one to spare
nope he's definitely gone what a shame
we'll try and pick up
uh with ted again talking about the fact
that
uh liverpool has lost its world heritage
status and no longer the taj mahal
of the north west um have a look at this
andalusia's regional parliament
had an unexpected visitor beloved
what are they looking at what could they
possibly be looking at a rat
took the parliament floor on wednesday
causing a fair bit
of disruption as you can imagine the
road and entered the room just ahead of
a vote leading to many lawmakers
jumping out of their seats and climbing
on the top
of them witnesses told local media the
rat was of
considerable size so a rat
in parliament insert gag here
let's find out what's happening as far
as the weather is concerned here's
kirstie
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning another hot and sunny day
is in store but changes are looming
for the weekend it will turn fresher but
rather more unsettled
let's take a look though through the
rest of the day we have oh you know what
i'm just going to check that back to the
beginning because the graphics have
skipped merely ahead without me
but very hot and sunny today talking
about the heatwave extreme heat warnings
ratio for the first time this week
by the met office now it's across parts
of northern ireland southern wales
and southwest england that's where most
likely to see the effect of these really
high temperatures both by day
and by night now of course that has
adverse effects on health it's really
difficult to sleep
in these humid nights temperatures today
will peak at around 31 or
32 celsius possibly the odd shower but
another uncomfortable night is going to
follow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
been talking about the pandemic this
morning and tamara
is with us tomorrow i was chatting to
the minister about it we'll talk about
it
in more detail during tomorrow's take
but he said he wasn't going to play a
game with me about who was going to be
on the list
yes and it's um he says it's a game but
as you're pointing out to him this is
actually deadly serious for
supermarkets and other businesses who
rely on deliveries
coming in we've already seen pictures of
empty supermarket shelves
all over our newspaper front pages
reports of petrol pumps running out of
petrol because so many lorry drivers
are self-isolating already we're seeing
the retail industry saying
the government needs to act now to have
exemptions for retail workers
to self-isolate but the government is
saying we're keeping these rules
in place until the 16th of august who
knows how big the problem
could get by then and also that that
list of exemptions
which we're going to get possibly today
is going to be very
tightly drawn there's sure to be some
people very angry not being on it he
also said that he didn't recognize the
images of those
bare supermarket shells
difficult to tell from a few pictures
whether the problem is widespread
across the country it's a bit like at
the beginning of the pandemic markets
are saying that it's right
all the supermarket chains are saying
this is tesco sainsbury's little
morrisons they're all saying that
they're having problems to some
extent with getting product onto the
shelves
and so this is something that the you
know the business sector is going to be
being
lobbied about by businesses themselves
and by mps but so far
the government is standing firm that
there will be a tightly drawn list of
exemptions
okay tomorrow for now thanks so much
talking about that in more detail
throughout the course
of the program of course um we will also
be talking um about the app the
uh have you been pinged do you still
have
the nhs app on your phone apparently a
third of people
have either deleted it or didn't have it
in the first place and others
have switched off the test and trace